Emily you're on the air hi dr. Wallach
thank you for making my phone call I
feel like I won the lottery your
questions one for myself and one for my
children who are pretty athletic it's
kind of just what to do for them they
will do one per one similar than okay
first okay will do me first I'm 37
I am 110 I'm pretty athletic I've been
doing the ketogenic lifestyle for about
nine months now but all of a sudden I
think what I have I kind of had
diagnosed myself but I think what I have
is and suppori ik dermatitis procedure
really yeah the really itchy scalp and
the cracked corners in my mouth and
really eat um flaky and just last year
let me ask you some questions here are
you're not driving eggs and murder but
itís okay they could be people Rick I'd
have to look at it but you know you're
kind of on the right track and I've ever
had skin problems as a teenager even
acne or anything like that
not really okay did you ever have any
things like asthma bronchitis no I've
been a big swimmer and runner for a long
long time did you ever believe anything
like colitis or - well sure drummer
diverticulitis no sir
doing it all just kind of happen within
the last few months okay now did you
have any brothers and sisters
not biologically okay and yeah so what I
suggest is is number one you need to
make sure that you're getting lots of
steamed vegetables I go ahead and have
steamed vegetables for breakfast lunch
and dinner I'd also have some eggs for
breakfast lunch and dinner you can have
poach your softball door soft trembling
butter
you can have a couple of tablespoons of
red meat in it rather
eggs every meal you get to have another
option is to take a couple of
tablespoons of poultry another option is
a couple tablespoons of fish okay we
have the what we call the keto caramel
shakes and Aikido caramel meal bars you
can take those but in the shakes again I
would have the thing is and instead of
making with water which you do if you
want to lose weight I'd go ahead and add
the things like any whipping cream or
half-and-half maybe a lot of that okay
good and then from a settlement
standpoint yeah yeah all right here we
take it 110 pounds one healthy bringing
the hardpack from one healthy brain and
heart Packer mugs I get an extra supply
extra bottle of a Accio so you could
take two servings of the ILA to FX plus
a day one breakfast one it's dinner time
I also have you take but also you have
to take the hair skin and nails I didn't
take three of those twice a day three or
breakfast trays every time there's two
bottles a month the castle's hair skin
and nail we have specific nutrients to
support the maintance repair of skin but
I'm personally giving you the healthy
range hardpack because it contains a
bottle of the he a phase about Olympic
pluses which take the three days at
breakfast and 3/5 plus it's dinnertime
and see if it doesn't help you with all
those sebaceous dermatitis or dermatitis
and just be hyper aware you want to be
sure to read labels and everything make
sure everything is gluten free
nothing is preparing on jointly shared
equipment that boxes or packages
products that's it
wheat or barley right over to them okay
everybody the Helen please dog you can't
the bird the fish is a study lab for
children they're not having fun but oh
well okay so good mysteries to go with
you